- [Interviewer] All right,
Repeat. It's all yours.
- [Repeat] All right.
My mom.
My mom grew up in Louisiana.
And she had two brothers.
And all through our childhood,
we would hear about hospitality
and how people in Louisiana were.
They treated you, you
know, and made you welcome.
Welcome to where you'd wanna go back.
My mom used to drink like a fish
until my father died in '67.
I remember looking up at my mom,
first time I can remember seeing her cry
and 'cause my father was dead.
I didn't know the reason.
And from that day on, she
never took another drink.
You know?
Well we, where I grew up,
I had to-
Well I was always like somebody
in challenging.
I was challenged in school
to where I wanted the highest grade.
I wanted the higher score.
I wanted to finish my test first,
I wanted to get more answers right.
So it was like a competition
thing always with me.
And I would realize that I
wouldn't know anyone competing.
That all of us was competing.
In fourth grade,
we were introduced to Algebra.
And it was so exciting at that age
because it was something we didn't know.
And the individual mathematician
who started teaching us
algebra in the fourth grade,
he would come once a week.
And he would give us these
problems that were phenomenal.
And he wouldn't give us the answer,
but he would give us the solution.
And we would work solution.
All of us would come up
with a. appropriate answer.
But there were other individuals who
didn't want us to achieve.
So I literally had to
fight to get to school
because, "Oh, you think you smart?"
Never know I'm not
smarter than anybody else.
I just tried harder.
And I just remembered.
So I had to fight to get to school.
And then the same people were
waiting for me after school.
So I had to fight to leave.
So I figured if I had to fight to get in
and fight to get out,
I might as well learn something
because I'm fighting for it anyway.
So, in junior high school
was when my change,
change in life started.
And again, it started when
I started scuba diving.
My dive partner, my instructor,
my teacher, my mentor
was from Bath, Maine.
White guy.
And he'd been to 'Nam.
And I mean, this guy was-
To me, he was Einstein.
And I would listen to
the conversation, man.
I'm out of the ghetto
and I'm ghetto conversation.
But I would hear,
you know, these affluent people.
I mean, mean heads, bean
heads, call it what you want.
I would hear them talk.
And I was so amazed at the conversation.
I said-
(laughs)
One day, maybe I'll have
conversations like that
So I aspired to increase my vocabulary.
I started aspiring to learn.
And with that inspiration,
with every gain,
every gain brings its own problems.
You know, I was always told,
"You think you're smarter
than everybody else."
I said, "I'm not smarter.
I just try harder."
You think you different,
you think you better?
I'm not better. I'm just different.
You know, I'm just different
from who and what you are
because I think different.
Anyway.
Anything you consistently do,
you're supposed to get better at.
So I did a lot of fighting.
I did a lot of fighting.
I knew I had to fight, you know?
And anything you keep doing
again, you get better at.
So I got somewhat better at it.
When I came out of prison,
I met somebody who changed
my life for a little while.
She was...
Absolutely a state.
She was so beautiful to me.
I mean to the rest of the
world too. But she was-
I would meet her at Pershing Square
when she come from work
or whatever and meet me.
And I would walk her back in here.
I really didn't like her over here
because she didn't really belong.
But on the way here from
Pershing Square to San Pedro,
I mean individuals would
make the strangest comments,
like what they wanted
to do to her sexually.
And I would hear this
and I would turn around.
And, "What did you say?"
And, "Oh, I'm not talking
to you, I'm talking to her."
And one thing I learned
in the military was,
whoever strikes first and strikes hard
and consistently strikes
has the greatest opportunity
or possibility of being victorious.
So conversation over. I would take off.
I would right hook, left, whatever.
And there was one particular incident
when this guy came down the street,
he was looking for trouble.
He had his shirt off. He
was kinda penitentiary buff.
And I was standing there talking
to the two security guards
in a particular program
where they allow people to
use the bathroom 24 hours.
And so I'm talking to them
and we hear them coming.
So we stopped and we looked and he's like,
"Yeah, I'm fixin' to fuck me of these."
He used the N word, which I really detest.
I mean, in prison, all my years in prison,
we had a lot of battles over that word.
A lot of good people die,
bad people, whatever.
So I particularly tell people,
I mean, I don't care what
your conversation about,
but when you're talking to me,
don't use the N word
and don't call me that
because that's one thing
I aspire not to be.
I try hard not to fit that,
not to wear that jacket.
So anyway, he stops in front of me.
And then he says, "Yeah, I'm
gonna fuck with somebody up.
Now who's going to be my first victim?"
And he turns around, he looks at me.
I'm standing there with the arms folded.
And he says, "You going
to be my first victim."
I said, "Oh, okay, no problem."
Took my coat off. Put my bag down.
And when it was over,
he looked different and he felt different.
And he knew, he knew
because a guy had asked me later, he said,
"When you hit him and he went
down, what was your thinking?"
I said, "I was thinking I
wasn't gonna let him back up.
Wasn't gonna give him the opportunity
to stand back up again."
Because I kept striking.
In the particular area I grew up in,
I had no idea that this area
had become a gang.
And it was basically like forties.
I had no idea.
I'm in prison and a younger individual
I knew from that location,
he came and said, "That's what we are."
And I'm trying to think, what is that?
What is, what does it represent?
"Oh, we Crips."
And I said, "Nah, Man.
I mean I'm from there
by location, not affiliation.
I'm not going to do it that way.
I'm gonna keep my particular walk.
I'm not fixin' to get
involved in the gang activity.
I mean, I got your back.
And you know, I have everybody
else's back that I know,
if and when it comes to it.
But I'm not fixin' to go
into the gang part of it."
One particular day.
And was this?
I think this was like
1984.
End of '84.
I had met this female
and she wanted to not sexually be involved
because she was a lesbian,
which is no problem.
I'm a lesbian too.
She wanted to, you know, take up with me
and make some money with
me in the ghetto way.
You know, so sell drugs.
So I gave her a little something and left.
And I came back about an hour later
to see how she was doing.
And I went off in the store.
I came out and I looked across the street
and I noticed, which wasn't
there when I went in,
there was a crowd.
And so I looked at the crowd
and I seen her in the middle of the crowd.
I see her gesticulating.
Moving her head and taking her body.
And I was wondering what was going on.
And I see this guy I'd never seen before.
He walks up to her. He's talking
to her and he pushes her.
And I'm like, what the f-
I'm thinking, what the f-?
So I crossed the street through traffic
and I walk up and she said,
"Oh, here comes Pete now.
You going to get it."
And they look at me
and I noticed two girls
I'd never seen before.
They back up.
And one goes in the little clutch purse.
And she pulled out a Snap 38.
She handed it to the other one.
She sticks in their pocket.
And you know, they got me covered.
I said, "All right, we're
going to do it this way."
I said, "I'll be back."
Run down the street.
Go through a shortcut.
My younger brother's shooting
dice with some friends.
I said, "Come on, man. Let's roll.
Call them Hollywood. Let's roll, man.
Motherfuckers drew down on me."
"They drew down?"
I said, "They drew down
on me, man. Let's go."
We go out to the next
block. Get in the car.
I reach under the
dashboard. Grab the Python.
Open it up. It's loaded.
I tuck it.
I say, "Pull around to mom's
house, put it in the driveway."
So we negotiate the turns.
He pulls in the driveway.
I get out of the car.
I says, "Meet me at the stop sign.
Wait for me right there."
So I march down the middle of the street
into main trafficking to (indistinct).
And I'm standing there and I'm
looking for the individuals.
I don't see them. The guy and two girls.
I catch him on my periphery in a Chevy.
They're about to make a
left turn and come by me.
I act like I don't see them
for another couple of seconds.
I reached in and I grab it,
and I go into the stance.
And I go into the
stance. They ducked down.
But see, I know that the rounds from a 357
is going to go through a car door.
It would go through an engine block.
So I sight over the chrome
stripping on the '64 Chevy.
And I put two rounds above
the chrome stripping.
And when I dropped the one
under the chrome stripping,
the person pops up.
A female pops up.
She'd been hit and
she's flailing her arms.
So the guy grabs her.
He throws her over and he
jumps in the driver's seat.
He's looking up and now like
this, trying to get it in gear.
And so now I'm thinking I
might as well blow it up.
So I tried to get the gas tank.
I put two rounds in the gas tank.
Don't go up.
And he negotiates the turn.
Clips the car. Pulls down the street.
And I take out the back window.
I never understood why
about three blocks down,
he shoot in the air two times.
I guess he was showing, don't pursue me.
We got something too.
So anyway, everybody in traffic, it just-
everybody jumped out of the cars and ran.
I mean, I would have did the same thing.
They evacuated the cars
and near down the street.
So I walked back over to my brother's car.
We get in and we drive off.
We had approximately,
I would say somewhere around 15 shootouts.
And when I say shootout, I mean, you know
us shooting at somebody else
and they're shooting at us.
And the thing with me is,
when the military trains you on something,
they put a couple of
thousand years of science
and untold billions of dollars into the,
you know, the training session.
So if you listen,
then the best experts in
the world on how to kill,
how to make sure the bullet
goes where it's supposed to.
Ballistic arching and everything else.
And I just take these
things into consideration,
especially Kentucky windage.
When you fire, see where
your round is going.
If it's short, lift it.
If it's going forward, lower it some.
So I didn't draw down on a lot of people
because the thing was,
in our neighborhood,
if you draw down, you're going to use it.
The worst thing you can do
is draw down on somebody,
pull out a pistol, and not use it.
Then you fall into another
category where you got a pistol,
you'll draw down, but you won't use it.
You have to use it.
There are a few things
that I've accomplished.
And these aren't good things.
Things I'm proud of.
Now that I think about them as an adult,
I wish I'd never done them.
Can't go back and scrub the past.
So living for the future to
probably pass some messes on.
If one person get it
and can avoid, you know,
what I've been through or
what I'm still going through,
then fantastic.
If nobody can avoid what I went through,
no one gonna put the message out there.
And this medium has turned out to be
one of the best things
that ever happened to me
because there are a lot of
unexpected surprises.
I ran into a guy I never
knew, but he knew me.
He knew me from watching this program.
And I was amazed.
I still carry that with
me to where, you know,
he wanted my autograph.
And I never thought I
achieved anything like that.
But he got to mention this.
He said, "Your story was great.
I mean, me and my wife loved it.
I mean, you know, you knew
what you were talking about.
It was real. And we loved it.
We told a lot of our friends
and they passed it on."
I shared it with my family.
My son...
should be getting out of
an incarcerated situation real soon.
I didn't know he was there.
My niece, Rose.
She was telling me, "You
need to check on your son.
You need to find out
what's going on with him.
Something's wrong."
And I really didn't get the message
because I was kind of, well, not too busy.
I was preoccupied with my own yo-yo life.
The ups and downs.
His mom's been trying to reach out to me
and I'm not taking that trip again.
So I really don't deal with it.
Don't want to, because I will never ever
go through that cycle again.
It was a bad time in my life.
But nothing compares to what
I recently went through.
The individual I was with,
the female I was with,
had just, for whatever reason,
told me that she needed some extra money.
And a lot of it.
It was critical for me because
it was like she was daring
me to go back to yesterday.
To relive the past.
I'm a type of person I
can look at some things
and I can figure out a way
to achieve an objective.
So at this time I did probably...
12 acts in 12 days and...
(laughs)
gave her what she asked for.
A lot of it.
And it was for her to
achieve her escape.
One thing she said,
she always told me that I was too violent.
And for her, she was right because I-
At the drop of the hat,
I take off on somebody.
But I wouldn't go looking for trouble.
They'd have to say something,
something derogatory towards
her and disrespectful to me.
So what she did was
she claimed to have lost her house key.
So I gave her mine.
Went out today, came back.
Knocking on the door. I couldn't get in.
I didn't know if anybody was home.
She was home, but she was
on quiet. Silent running.
So I left.
Went grocery shopping.
Came back with a couple
hundred dollars worth of food.
And I'm still trying to get
in. I know she'll pop up.
So I sit there.
A little while later, the police show up.
When they show up, the way they come in,
I know, I mean there's no doubt about it.
I know they're coming for me.
I just can't figure
out why. What did I do?
So, you know, they draw down.
Lay me down in the hallway, cuff me up,
and take me out to the car.
And say I violated a restraining order.
There's no restraining order against me,
but it was what she told them.
That she had a restraining
order. She didn't.
However, when they put me
in the car, I gave him,
I gave him a Bunco. I gave him an alias.
And he typed it in and he said,
"No, let's try this name."
And when he put my real name in,
there was no doubt in my mind
that she had given it to him.
That she had set this whole move up
and I could not understand why.
So, I mean, when something's
too difficult to understand,
I stop trying. I stop
trying to understand.
Either it'll come to me or it won't.
But what she did was she got rid of me.
She got rid of me so that
she could make her egress.
And she did.
I did a little time in Little Beirut,
what they call the County Jail.
Because when you, when
you going to LA County,
(laughs)
you might not live to get out.
And it's a racial riot
just about every day.
And I'm a little bit, well a lot older
than I was when I went in as a youngster
looking forward to these activities.
I don't look forward to them
because not everybody
lives to get through them.
The County Jail, they had
their rules and regulations,
but each race has a variety
of rules and regulations
that makes it so much more unbearable.
So much harder for an
individual to get through.
So as an older individual,
they usually put us in
the old man's dorm where,
there's a lot less politics.
Or myself, the veterans' dorm.
So they have me in the veterans' dorm
with watered down politics.
There're still politics,
but they're watered down.
I came out of the County Jail
and I ran into her a couple of times
and just decided to let her go.
And I have. I think about it,
but I decided to let her go.
However, for a while I was on that...
I was on that self destruction mode.
I was literally really, really trying to
be destroyed.
I didn't want to do it myself.
Somebody who's going to facilitate me.
Somebody who's going to help me.
So I did a lot of things
that I wouldn't normally do.
I mean, even when Eva did all those stunts
because he didn't give a fuck.
I didn't give a fuck.
I put myself in a lot of
perilous situations where people-
not the police.
Oh, I really don't deal with them.
I avoid them at all costs.
But I put myself in the some situations.
I mean, I put out a gang of money
and let three guys follow
me into the alley just to
(laughs)
see how it was going to turn out.
As it turned out, I came out. They didn't.
I don't know where I was psychologically,
but that self destruct.
And then, you know the mind altering,
mood changing substances.
(laughs)
They were a great help.
Not on the courage factor,
but on the ability to
stay focused for a while.
Because after that, I mean,
it's dead to the world
My...
There's 11 of us in my family.
There was 11.
Two of my brothers died a
year apart. Both at age 21.
Yeah.
They went out in
tremendous fashion.
And what I mean by that
is, I mean heartbreaking.
That changed my mother's life.
It changed our family
structure. Changed everything.
We used to be tighter than
the skin on a golf ball.
I mean, have you ever
tried to feel a golf ball?
Somewhere along the line, we
well, the older ones,
gravitated towards their own interests
and this family fell apart.
I really don't communicate with my family.
I mean, a couple of members, you know.
And a few other ones.
Hi and bye. How you doing?
My younger brother is here with me.
We don't get along.
But I love him. He loves me.
I'm not going to let
nothing happen to him.
He's not going to let
nothing happen to me.
If it does,
then it's going to be-
It's going to be repercussions.
I just started back.
Well, trying to talk to my daughter.
I can't tell you how that's
going, because I have no idea.
I just take it as it comes.
I'm not necessarily winning.
I am maintaining the purpose.
And it's just about time
for me to get up out of here.
Not because this place is any different
from any other place.
I mean, you, I mean, you got
a lot of people doing nothing.
And a lot of drugs and everything else.
I mean, just concentrated.
But I can do from here
the same thing I can
do from anywhere else.
If I made up my mind to. When I decide to.
And I've made that decision.
I'm going to escape Alcatraz,
you know, escape from here.
I am going to.
Monday I should be back at work.
I'm going there. They'll rehire me.
I mean, I didn't leave
under bad conditions.
I left under good conditions.
And I work hard.
I can, and I will.
I'm not leaving this
because I'm scared.
I'm not leaving because I'm tired.
I'm leaving it because
there's a graduated process.
I mean, upward and onward.
And I'm going to
show a few other people how.
I don't know their reasons for being here.
Their reasons for living.
Their reasons for leaving.
I mean, I don't know.
But what I do know
is I have grandchildren now
that I never physically seen.
Never spoken to.
And I been here about, I been
on this side about four years.
I've never embraced them.
I've never shaken hands.
I've never sat down and ate with them.
I've never taken them anywhere.
I've never presented them anything.
I've never met them.
Other than a phone conversation,
a couple of minutes
because, for me, it's so uncomfortable.
And it should be. It's supposed to be.
It's supposed to be uncomfortable
because I put it off for so long.
I have six grandchildren
and I've never met one of them.
The only person I've actually
seen was my second eldest.
My son.
I haven't seen my daughter.
I haven't seen my youngest.
But I'm going to.
There are some things that I-
Well, I was thinking at one time that
leaving here, I had to clean up
a few messes that, you
know, I've encountered.
A few people.
And I really was.
I mean, I had it, not mapped out,
because you don't have to map it out here.
I'll run into them.
And I was going to let a
few down. A few of them.
But I've decided not to.
I'm not going to. That's not my position.
That's not. I can't do another 31 years.
I can't do another 31 days in prison.
I don't want to.
I got something else to do.
And I've listened to
a lot of individual stories on here.
And I thought I had it hard.
Everybody had it hard in
their own individual way.
Because when the strong get
hungry, the weak don't eat.
I mean, you get fed down here,
but we talking Darwin's
theory of the fittest.
You can really see it here.
No matter who,
when an individual first
came here, I told him.
I said, "If you got any
property that you want to keep,
when you leave, put it on your
back and take it with you."
He would wonder why I had
three or four backpacks.
I said, "Because everything in here
is something I want to maintain.
And tell me if you don't
want it, just leave it.
It'll disappear on its own.
It will go, go to where the dinosaurs."
I don't want to do any
more fighting down here.
I mean, I'm not a good runner,
so I'm not going to run.
But I've tried a different
way to avoid conflict.
It felt strange. It felt funny.
It felt like I was, I think
the word is eating crow.
And I felt kind of, well, not kind of,
I felt humiliated just by backing down.
I mean, I had no doubt in my mind
how it would have turned out.
It would've looked different
and felt different.
But I just didn't want to.
And I wanted to try it another way.
And I tried it. It didn't
feel good at first.
But I think in time, it's
supposed to come easier
to avoid conflict or walk away from it
instead of going head on into it.
I'm obviously a lot older.
I'm not as handsome as
I once thought I was.
I'm not as quick as I believe to be.
I'm not as skilled as I want to be.
Those aren't the reasons why
I don't want to participate anymore.
The reason why I don't
want to participate anymore
is because I'm...
searching for a new purpose.
A new direction.
I can't say that a new
purpose and a new direction
is going to be better,
but I can say it's going to be different.
And it starts with me
making different decisions.
You know the saying,
trying to do the same
thing a different way?
It doesn't work out well.
To get new results, I
have to try new things.
And Monday I start on something new.
I won't make it out of here Monday,
but I will go to work Monday.
And that's a great beginning for me.
Haven't done it in a
while, but I'm going to.
Most people want to go to SSI.
I can do that, but I don't want to
because there's still
some work left in me.
And I want to go do this time.
I've made my decision.
- [Interviewer] Good for you man.
I'm proud of you.
- Fantastic.
- [Interviewer] I'll miss you.
- No. (laughs)
If you're here, you will see me
because I've seen some people
come through and talk about,
you know, how, Hey, I
used to sleep right here.
I used to do that.
And it's just so amazing.
They bring their family to show them
where they've been, what they've done.
And it's one of those success stories.
And I plan on being one.
- [Interviewer] Come on back when you do.
- Fantastic. I will definitely.
Alright.
- [Interviewer] Thank you, man.
- You're welcome.
Yeah, Monday I go back to...
(faded talking)